hello i'm leonard engelmann I am a
makeup artist and hairstylist branch
governor it's my honor to be your host
and on behalf of the academy of motion
picture arts and sciences and the makeup
artist and hairstylist branch to welcome
you to the 87th academy awards event and
the 33rd Oscar nomination for makeup and
hairstyling we have a number of guests
and the first guest I'm very honored to
introduce you to is the Los Angeles
Mayor Eric Garcetti please welcome mayor
Garcetti thank you so much Leonard and a
very good afternoon everybody thank you
all for being here members of the
Academy distinguished guests and friends
fellow Angelenos good afternoon and
welcome to Oscar weekend in Los Angeles
we are so excited this weekend when the
world's eyes turned to Los Angeles but
they don't just do that on one weekend
because of these awards they turn here
all the time because of what we create
here in this great town and I'm so proud
that Los Angeles is the creative
crossroads of the world the
entertainment capital not just of the
United States but of this globe and that
the Academy Awards will again focus the
world's eyes on what we do and what we
have done today I'm really honored to be
here among you some of our entertainment
industry's best and brightest and to
make it clear you know that it isn't
just about those faces that we will see
on the red carpet but it's those folks
that are below the line who bring the
magic to those faces that we see to
their hair to their faces and to be
clear I had nobody from the Academy do
my makeup today so my my apologies for
doing it myself but I want to
congratulate the nominees it's an
extraordinary road that you have taken
to be here to be recognized by your
peers I know it's a cliche that we thank
all the nominees but before there is a
single winner picked out all three of
you all three of the nominees really
represent the most extraordinary
creativity and focus let's give our
nominees a round of applause
and congratulate them for what they have
done I also want to give a special
welcome to some special guests that are
here from Los Angeles Unified School
District Hollywood High School to be
exact are there some sheiks in the house
make some noise sheiks I was so proud to
be your council member for 12 years now
to be your mayor Hollywood High School
is literally right there in the best
location the best real estate in the
world when it comes to Hollywood it
isn't just an industry at a place and
those two have become more unified
together and I really appreciate that
the Academy brings our future
entertainment workers and that's what we
see you guys as being the magic makers
of tomorrow into the magic of this
weekend as well and as mayor and even
though i'm a sag aftra member myself i
understand the lifeblood of the industry
is actually the folks not on the silver
screen but the folks behind it the two
people who build the sets it's the
people who light them to the people who
drive the trucks those below the line
hard-working people who are the true
backbone of our film industry and of
la's middle class there you define who
we are as a city you attract tourists to
come here you helped fuel other creative
industries and it's why I'm so committed
to making sure that the film industry
continues to stay and grow here in Los
Angeles
the recession that we've just emerged
from hurt us all and powerful incentives
from out of state and out of the country
mean that too often if there is work
it's not here in Los Angeles that is
divided families it's helped week in our
main streets and our economies but I
heard loud and clear from you those
folks who do this work members of local
706 for instance and others below the
line brothers and sisters who said do
something mr. mayor and last year we
made it the highest priority of the
state level to bring a robust package of
tax incentives back to California and
against a lot of skepticism even
cynicism in Sacramento we got and we
thank the governor for signing the tax
package we put forward that will bring
six billion dollars of production over
the next five years back to California
and today I'm here because I want to
share with you the next phase of our
strategy in our campaign to continue to
make Los Angeles the only place that you
want to film the agenda to reverse
runaway production to build up our
entertainment industry to strengthen the
middle class today we are launching
green light Hollywood our new campaign
to highlight y los angeles is the best
place with the most talented people with
the most compressed creativity anywhere
in the face of the world and to
understand all of the incentives that we
will offer for filming here in los
angeles my film office which i
established for the first time in city
hall led by the legendary entertainment
attorney Ken Zefram and his deputy
received alone will help lead a
volunteer group of labor production and
marking marketing executives to meet
with studio executives with packaging
agents finance seers and managers to
detail the provisions of the new tax
credit program and discuss how much more
beneficial it is both creates it
creatively and financially to be here in
LA but this campaign will also recruit
and deploy a core of entertainment
professionals and please join us if
you'd like to be a part of that to
identify film and TV productions in the
planning stages that would be most
beneficial to la's economy if produced
here these green light hollywood
representatives would then contact
productions through
studio green light committees and make
the case for filming in LA just at those
moments when people are making those
critical decisions in Los Angeles we
have a whole host of incentives whether
it's in television making it free to
film a pilot here waving those fees
coordinating now between city
departments to make it much more
seamless between our fire department and
our rec and Parks and our transportation
departments to make filming easy here
but we understand that our filming
industry is essential not just in
today's reputation but tomorrow's future
here in LA and making sure that la
remains the entertainment capital of the
world it's simple we're going to knock
on the door of every decision maker here
in Hollywood and I want you to help put
them to work in LA so thank you again
for what you do I always say that LA and
California we didn't have to have the
deepest tax incentive because we have
the best talent we need to be more
competitive but our secret weapon is you
the most talented committed magic makers
anywhere in the world I know you're
going to see a taste of that today and
we'll see certainly see it highlighted
again tomorrow night but thank you for
what you do and let's make sure this
truly is a city of dreams once again
thanks
it's my honor to to be here and to
introduce you to some great nominees
Oscar week makeup artist and hairstylist
symposium can now be seen on our website
at oscars org so we welcome viewers
hopefully around the world the nominated
films this year are wonderful examples
of the very vast range that is the art
of makeup and the vast range of the
selection process within the makeup
artist and hairstylist branch our first
film the grand Budapest hotel is
recognized for makeup and hairstyling
for the film in its entirety our second
film guardians of the galaxy is also
recognized for makeup and hairstyling
for the entire film our third film
foxcatcher is recognized for makeup for
the characters of John du Pont Mark
Schultz and David Schultz so we have the
grand Budapest hotel guardians of the
galaxy and foxcatcher now we have a
number of people in the audience I would
like to recognize and I would like to
introduce another governor for the
makeup artist and hairstylist branch and
that's bill Corso we could just bring
our lights up again
and we have a number of Oscar nominees
and recipients as I call your name would
you please stand and remain standing
until we get to the last the last name
please we have V Neil bill Corso Michael
is all d ed French Trevor proud
Deborah Lumia denver Howard Berger
christina smith Tammy Lane Martin Samuel
mark cole yay and robin mathews
thank you very much I would like to
recognize from the makeup artist and
hairstylist branch local 706 president
Zuccarelli Burt business representative
Tommy Cole an assistant business
representative Randy Sayer and I
especially would like to thank the
Academy's group Mary Mary Rose mcmayhem
and her team for all the work that goes
into making this such a successful event
this is a wonderful time for the six
nominees to bask in their
accomplishments and recognition some of
you in the audience may have contributed
these films and should be sharing in the
glory so audiences enjoy this time
applaud make noise celebrate with the
nominees because that's what this is all
about let's start right now
today is a celebration of winners every
nominee that steps on this stage is a
winner every nominee tomorrow is the
winner one film group will carry statues
but every nominee is a winner the reason
the Academy gives Academy Awards is to
honor and celebrate the art and science
of motion pictures it's why the Academy
exists the Oscar exists because the
founders believed that movies were not
just business and that people needed to
be reminded of that the Oscar exists to
tell the world that filmmaking is an art
and it's being practiced by some people
at a very high level and some of those
people are in this room today before we
hear from our Oscar nominees I'd like to
explain the process that brought us to
today in April october november they
make a partisan hit hairstylist
executive branch and the membership meet
and as part of the business they discuss
a list of films that have been released
during the previous months these are
films these members feel should be seen
for makeup and hairstyling the list is
then sent to all branch members so that
they can be aware of them therefore they
can the films can be continually
recommended or possibly not in December
all branch members were asked to attend
a meeting to vote for the seven films
that will go on for consideration for
nomination these are selected as the
seven best films for achievement in
makeup and hairstyling for the year I
always like to point out how unbiased
these selections are as i read the names
of the seven films and the members that
the members in attendance chose we have
of these seven we had the amazing
spider-man 2 shot in New York
foxcatcher shot in pennsylvania the
grand budapest hotel shot in germany and
poland guardians of the galaxy shot a
little bit in california but almost
completely in england Maleficent shot in
England the theory of everything shot in
England and Noah shot in Iceland Noah
wanted to shoot in England but all of
the really good locations were already
taken you can see seven great
accomplishments in the artistry of
makeup and hairstyling of 16 possible
nominees 11 were not Academy members or
I iatse local 706 members of 16 possible
nominees for have Oscars of seven films
selected three films have no Academy
members the selections of these films
and their possible nominees is complex
for we recognize the specific makeup and
hairstyling achievement in a film in
some cases this may be the film in its
entirety for makeup or for hair styling
or for both makeup and hairstyling or it
may be for a specific character or
characters for makeup or makeup and
hairstyling and from that we recognize
the artist or artists most responsible
for these achievements following the
December meeting the makeup artist and
hairstylist executive committee meets
this is probably the most difficult of
all of the meetings because the
committee now has to choose a maximum of
two individuals possibly three for those
most responsible for the look that Ben
is being recognized in each film or
character and characters so it doesn't
matter what the ads may say it doesn't
matter how much was spent in advertising
it doesn't matter what someone's deal
memo said and it doesn't matter the
film's credits at that point the exact
committee has to make the decision based
on input and the work that was done in
1968 prior to there being a yearly Oscar
for makeup Planet of the Apes was going
to receive a special Academy Award there
was to be one statue that award as was
the process of the time was to go to the
makeup department head for 20th Century
Fox that was dance tree peck dan said
the person most responsible for this
achievement is john chambers and he must
receive the Oscar it is that standard of
honesty and responsibility that we
follow today as the committee
painstakingly chooses the individuals
most responsible for what has been
recognized in each film then in January
all members met and were asked to attend
a presentation by the makeup artist and
hairstylist recognized for the seven
films this is often referred to as a
bake-off this is when the final
nominations were chosen for the Academy
Award for makeup and hairstyling for
2014 as you can see the makeup artist
and hairstylist Academy members spend a
great amount of time very unselfish time
in an effort to applaud the work of
others today you're actually going to
see how that process takes place I'm
going to ask each of the nominees to
talk about some of the work on their
film that you're going to see and what
you'll see in the film clips will then
show the 10 minute clips so you can see
the wonderful work after the third clip
has been seen we will open the floor for
questions of the nominees followed by an
opportunity to join the nominees and see
displays representing their films
downstairs in the lobby you will love
that now let's meet our nominees
our first nominated film is grand
Budapest hotel please welcome Francis
Hannon Francis please come up and take a
seat Francis's credit as hair makeup and
prosthetic designer this is the first
oscar nomination for francis francis is
presently filming now you see me too
with woody harrelson mark ruffalo and
Morgan Freeman shortly she will be
working on Iran Howard film inferno
starring tom hanks and and please
welcome mark cole yay mark is credited
for prosthetics this is the second Oscar
nomination for mark he has 11 Oscar for
the Iron Lady
mark is presently involved with the
James Bond movie spectra and zoolander
to the grand budapest hotel won the
bafta award for makeup and hairstyling
two weeks ago and last week at the
makeup artist and hairstylist Guild
Awards Francis received the best period
and our character makeup award and the
best period and our character
hairstyling award for the grand Budapest
hotel and Francis I believe that you
have a special guest here today possibly
not hello ah I have Tony here he belongs
to the makeup department and he's very
kindly come along today to join us so 20
River Lori he played 0 in the grand
Budapest hotel
now I have been wanting to ask this
question because I think it's just such
a great part of the film why do you want
to be a lobby boy well who wouldn't at
the grand Budapest there so then I love
that line there are so many great
characters in this film and we're going
to take a look at a lot of them but you
were so unique with the changes that
took place and everything and a lot of
those changes were sort of almost based
on a mustache to a certain degree you
know sometimes there was a mustache
sometimes there wasn't sometimes the
mustache as he got older the mustache
became larger and you know I thought it
was just a great look we're going to
take a look here at a little bit of that
okay and you can see here some of them I
want to go forward one here this this
was such a great unique character now
was this mustache it is described in the
script um no I don't recall the mustache
been in the script at all do you Tony no
it was not it was a if i recall
correctly I remember I went to Germany
to meet with Wes for the first time and
you as well and I believe that's when he
first told me about I don't know when he
told you about it but that's when I
first told me we discussed it was sort
of based on the fact that he wanted to
emulate Gustav so then he said I attack
that I couldn't grow one yeah yeah yeahs
too so he penciled it on which tony had
to do by himself most times as you can
see in the photo he nearly got it in his
nose rather than above his liver but him
he had to do that as director cameron
O'Mara
so I think he did very well but I'm as
he progressed in character he grew his
own mustache which we stuck on yeah that
was a that was fun and it's actually
really funny that I'm when you watch the
film different like you said there's
different portrayals of the mustache he
always has it on when he's with Monsieur
Gustave and whenever he's with Agatha
alone saoirse ronan he doesn't have the
mustache which is like something very
very beautiful to the film and we played
on and was fantastic well it was
interesting too because as I look back
it seems to me you're in almost every
shot now in almost every sequence a
great part of it so you know for
something that started off maybe small
it i think that became huge for you you
know yeah without a doubt it was it was
fantastic I mean working with all these
people many of which have worked with
Wes a lot on previous films you did
Rushmore Emily yeah and so it's it's
difficult to come in as a new guy but
everyone there is so nice and gentle
that they just help you feel comfortable
and you don't really feel any pressure
later on right I'm going to go back to
what we saw just a moment ago because
the Ralph Ennis as as mr. Gustave was
such a great character and always so
perfectly done I mean even in prison he
even when he was beat up he was almost
perfectly done you know what was all
involved in his character as far as the
makeup and hairstyling he was one of the
most difficult to find exactly in the in
the very early prep days because he
gustav because of looked like so many
different things but once Rafe and we
both know he is a meticulous artist we
decided that he should have a blonde
toned wig which was fairly fully it was
only missing a little bit of the nape
that was his own hair and he grew his
own mustache but
he loved blonde women and so where's
wanted him to have a blonde tinge
himself so every day what Rafe was waked
and foundation eyebrows mascara blush
sure he was the full works he was based
on really a 1930s Hollywood star but in
a very subtle way ok great great let's
move on here obviously one of the the
centerpieces of the film is Madame D
played by Tilda Swinton now how did this
wonderful character come about this was
a combination with with you mark and and
with you Francis and some beautiful
beautiful work well where's cast Tilda
after he lost the lead lady who was an
older lady and he called to ask did I
think we could make her 83 even though
she was only 50 and it's it very well
into the film and not stand out as a
caricature so I called mark who's worked
with me before and made beautiful fine
pieces and between us we designed her
overall look many pieces a very high
plumpie pompous wig that balanced the
prosthetics makeup and then her
beautiful costume and I think her
overall look her teeth and a contact
lens is set very well into the film yeah
yeah that's right and you know the first
I heard of it Francis gave me a call and
said would I be interested in working on
a Wes Anderson movie and especially
particularly aging Tilda Swinton to
being a t3 which was just amazing you
know we were like in the crew you know
just go into the cruise I know you guys
fancy do aging up Tilda Swinton and it
was like absolutely you know such a
dream dream job anyone who's makeup
artist knows that working on someone
with a great bone structure and a real
really fine look is the perfect person
to age the hollow cheeks you know you
know it was it was it was just it was
just perfect and you know till does such
a lovely creative person as well it was
a real pleasure a real joy to work on
him and then you know we did all sorts
of things there's a picture there of the
the old-age stipple around the eyes we
we actually got a similar we didn't have
access
tilda at all so we got a similar lady
with a similar look in and I got her
into the workshop and we we did various
tests on various old edge to pull
makeups around the eyes we really didn't
want to put prosthetics under her eyes
wanted to use all that natural aging you
know it's such a great technique the
old-age stipple in on certain skins and
if somebody's over 50 it works
particularly well so I really wanted to
avoid prosthetics around the eyes so we
kept the we kept the peace really low
under her cheekbone Tilda's got really
wide cheekbones so we also didn't want
to add any material to the outside of
her cheekbones to create that Sal oh
look and I should really credit Duncan
jarman and Stephen Murphy here as well
who really worked did an enormous amount
of work on this on this makeup and josh
weston who sculpted the hands for it we
did 10 prosthetics which are on display
at the back and then in combo with
friends lovely beautiful wig and and
then the makeup we basically stuck the
prosthetics on and painted everything
into her skin and wed soy tu ma need
loads of liver spots and then fran and
it was a julie darnell and did the
straight makeup and the lipstick and
eyeshadow and the whole thing just
really came together and you know once
once she emerged with Molina's beautiful
sumptuous costume on it was a real
striking character you know she had
heels on the wig was really high so I
think she was about 7 foot taller
something where that I would village I
was towering underneath her and and one
interesting thing that happened was Jeff
Goldblum was there and he's had loads of
prosthetics on you know it's been
undergone the whole process as the fly
you know and he went over and he was
just really amazed but you know because
the new materials the silicon works
really well looks really like real skin
you know so he was really it was it was
a nice moment for him to come over and
really compliment us on the makeup and
how many pieces did you have on her we
had 11 pieces in total we had to two
hands cheeks a little chin piece neck
too little nose pieces on the side of
the nose we didn't want to change your
nose particularly but there's a textural
thing of you know you just want to
create a
bit of texture in this we did too little
tiny pieces here for head peaks which
was an out of a flat mold and he loves
the sort of long dangly he loves which
we exaggerated really quite a lot and
then the wig understand the wig was not
just a wig there were several pieces to
the wig we made the wig out five pieces
because we wanted the height but we
didn't want the bulk around the rest of
it so I built it up I had it made of 20
inch length hair and then added two more
pieces on the top and then too there are
cool flanges at the back of the nape of
the neck which made Tilda's head look
even longer than it was and I think it
worked very well you agree here we shall
have a shot of Tilda in the process and
then let's take a look at this poster
because it shows so many great great
characters Harvey Keitel one of the
great characters that are in there and
what it would what were all the
different processes you had on Harvey I
had him head cast in America because we
had no access to Harvey which was sent
to mark so we only got Harvey I think
two days prior to the shoot which is a
very short time mark made the ball camp
we'd done all the tattoos we didn't know
where would place them or how they'd
look if they'd work and I made him some
teeth he didn't have contact lenses he
didn't want them I made him some
plumpers for his nose to make it look
slightly broken mark made him a nose to
and and he had to sit there naked from
the waist up i'll never know why but it
was his choice
yeah we did we did is his bald cap which
is you know the two most difficult
makeups as far as I'm concerned or bald
caps and old-age makeups that we do as
prosthetic makeup artist so it was a it
was quite a nice challenge you know to
get both of those in one movie and I've
done a few silicon ball caps before but
it was a really nice one to do on Harvey
he was great he really loves the process
is a real pro you know ex-marine so me
and Duncan German stuck it on and Duncan
and him just talked about SS daggers and
all sorts of weird things that they
collect and because they're both
collectors of weaponry and stuff and so
he was great fun you know it's a really
really tricky makeup to do but it was it
was good fun one of the characters that
I really liked also was Adrien Brody and
I didn't realize it actually until I was
listening to the real that you had put
together that as we look at Adrian
wherever he is here we see a very high
hairstyle and I understand that that was
to relate more to the look of his mother
yes it was he was sort of that when they
were had time together he sort of tried
to emulate his mother though he
obviously didn't like her very much I
don't think but him he was based on an
artist called Egon Schiller from the
period and we kept it along the same
lines I mean obviously not the waves but
the exact precision of the moustache and
slightly gothic makeup to time with his
sisters but he balance Madame D out very
well i think in stature and in body size
actually well and also William Dafoe
great a great sort of subtle look but
sort of a bulldog look I made the
selection of teeth you'll see them on
the display because we didn't get woolum
in advance we didn't really know where
we would go with his character so I made
some bull dog teeth as you see and we
made them for the top and the bottom but
we found when we actually fitted him the
day prior to shoot that only the bottom
ones really made the huge difference
to his mouth and made him very different
so he came with long hair down to he
showed us we cut it all off very badly
for the film to a very short crop and we
scared him as well he had a pro bonders
girl from his head down to his eyebrow
and where's his brief was that he wanted
him to look as rough as Willam could
again with the Gothic look because
Adrien Brody was his master very good
well when we see the film clips here
you're going to see with Tony you know
the looks in the beginning you're going
to see the the looks towards the end
with what looks like a lot longer hair
and mustache and all and I think you're
going to enjoy this Tony thank you so
much for joining us that graduate Thank
You gravity hang and we're going to ask
the nominees to take their seats please
welcome for guardians of the galaxy
Lizzie yani George Oh Lizzie is credited
as the makeup and hair designer this is
the first Oscar nomination for Lizzie
last Saturday at the makeup artist and
hairstylist Guild Awards Lizzie received
the best contemporary makeup award this
is branching into new areas with
possible skincare line and is possibly
co-producing a script and please welcome
David White
david is credited as a special makeup
effects designer this is the first oscar
nomination for david and last saturday
at the makeup artist and hairstylist
guild award David receive the best
special makeup effects award david is
presently involved in the Huntsman and
miss peregrine's home for peculiar
children now Lizzy I believe that you
have a special guest also yes we do have
we've got the wonderful Michael Rooker
who plays yon doing guardians of the
galaxy thank you there's a huge number
of characters with a tremendous changes
from facial hair and body structure to
vibrant comic book colors so let's take
a look first at the Michaels character
here
Michael would you describe the look of
this character and how this took place I
was asleep most of the time the makeup
took about four half hours we started
with the prosthetic head piece actually
I've had my hair cropped since the movie
yeah yeah I used to have a wonderful
little red mohawk that we dyed red
because as we were developing the
character we didn't know whether we
would want you know a red mohawk in hair
but David had our ideas I don't know
where that piece went but the strangest
thing is I had to incorporate make
hollow out the actual prosthetic piece
to accommodate your very own I had a
mohawk yeah I had my hair cut actually I
I did it myself and and I and I went
over to London and I wanted it to be a
surprise for James Gunn so we were to
meet it was a little crooked it wasn't
that really good so we're here to meet
and have dinner it's so the for his
first look I i had the mohawk and I was
very proud of it and I made it a push
pooped it up a little bit and he came in
to join me for dinner and the first
remark was just a big giant belly laugh
so it worked I wanted it to be a joke
and but it looked I got used to it I so
I kept it and they accommodated it they
hollowed out the whole deal and made me
very proud so in this in this picture is
this your hair or is it a piece you know
what this piece it looks it looks like
it's growing out of my skull yeah how do
you yeah it was designed that way but
it's actually a like Apollo 3 in Section
a semi-rigid section down the center
there to get that real metal feel to it
with a silicon surround and then the
other prosthetics we have three other
prosthetics running down the right so
Michael's face there that are a transfer
silicon pieces and those were the the
little scaria pieces that you know we
kept having a lot of fun with like every
time we put a bottle of jager does it go
this way or this way and then Michael
had the product that we developed for
guardians of the galaxy in the different
color blue so that was layered on in
three layers airbrushed on we developed
it because when we were testing
everything we found that everything
wasn't quite to sort of James Gunn's
expectations and as it was vibrant and
ER for tiden and I think because James
always used to come right up close to
the actor and kind of say look I can
still see that this is a human being so
you know we kind of tested so many
different products and in the end I just
knew that we had to make our own we knew
that we'd be shooting in the heat of the
summer and big leather costumes and we
didn't want it to come come off and we
we knew we wouldn't have time to be
really messing around with lots of
makeup checks because once these guys
were on they were on and high-definition
cameras no specific lighting for the
actors everything was kind of lit for
the movie so no loading for me well we
didn't have special like I felt it was
all from me I've called just the Michael
of course so that's that's when we
decided to sort of make our own product
and like I said to a lot of other makeup
artists to kind of shared the secret
it's no longer a secret it's got a gas
permeable layer that means that Michael
did a very funny trick on the first day
that I actually used it on him because
we tested it on on our juniors and sort
of other models before Michael came to
the chair and he was one of the first
artists that we tested the makeup on and
we actually applied it in four layers
and then painted on all the little
little blood vessels and roughened him
up a little bit and contoured him as
well we have different colors and he
decided he told me he was going to the
loo but what he did do was run around
the block about three times just to test
our makeup so when I was looking for I
went looking for him the producers
arrived
and James Gunn arrived to come and have
a look at this lovely look that we've
done for him this guy was coming up the
stairs completely perspiring and
everything any kind of it it works you
know it really works look it's not
coming off so that was the test that was
the big test for us it was a big test
for me because you know I don't want to
be messed around with my headset now and
stuff and I was a little concerned that
it was going to run or something like
that and so my test my personal test was
go out and into a workout and and to see
if I could you know see it like it's wet
through makeup and have it not and have
its day and it did it did you can
perspire through the makeup and so that
made the skin look even more realistic
now didn't you also have problems then
with the adhesives because yeah yeah
well with Michael we didn't have to use
wig lose but when we started to use it
on other actors that were using the
different colors we found that the wig
glues were breaking down the membrane of
the product so we then had to develop
our own wig glue to you know accommodate
it which was just another version of
what we'd already done but it was
tweaked and made into a glue which
lasted all day long it was brilliant we
had it on Gomorrah we had it on quite a
few of the other artists so it is a
wonderful group let's take a look at
some of those artists here we've got
here we've got Chris Pratt great look
and I think you had you made some
changes on him didn't we did we did when
he kind of arrived with it when I first
saw pictures of Kris proud of my mind
went into sort of overload how are we
going to make this guy look completely
different to parks and recreations and
make him you know like where did hear
our flex and go gadget him yeah we made
impex and recreations instead well
actually he did that for himself as well
though because he used to work out every
morning I mean he worked really hard for
this part but we kind of chiseled his
face and got him to grow a little bit of
facial hair and added to that as well
just to sort of make him look a bit more
so out there and i kind of wanted people
to relate to him so
I kind of gave him there the sort of the
thicker hair and that kind of hairstyle
that kind of made him look more hero
like he was turned up as well we did
turn him up and for those shots that you
see up there now you know he did help a
little bit but he I mean the guy where
it's harder to go to give him up yeah
and then it got a little bit more
complex with Gomorrah played by zoe
saldana and also ronan played by lee
pace definitely Oh comoros and fish all
her pieces are if they were all done by
I'm David and his team yep so we're
looking at the silicone prosthetic
forehead silicon cheeks little pieces
here mainly stuck umatilla assists with
a little bit of pro Sade in areas as
well so as a combination they're very
very thin pieces but it just gives a
little a lino jande direction very
symmetrical for the kind of a
biomechanical structure that was
sculpted in there so she's out there but
she's still you know you can still
relate to her that was the idea we
didn't we tried lenses and in fact
didn't we we had all sorts of things
going on and you needed to relate to her
so we took off the lenses and just went
with her that was the idea of giving her
the funky hairstyle as well the funky
diff time two tone hair color because I
wanted sort of young people of today to
kind of relate to her so she kind of
gave her a little edge so that you know
she didn't just dump out of a comic book
he kind of felt like you know somebody
you might know mm-hmm because that's the
thing with the comic books you know what
you see in the what you see in those
comic books it can be too extreme for a
movie it just doesn't quite relate so we
had to turn things down and it's going
to go to work on that massive scale so
it has to be really believable in that
and then we've met Drax yeah lot of work
here load of work on Drax I mean you
know when David was cast I mean what a
fantastic physique he's got I mean
there's there's no way that I wanted to
start putting enormous quantities of
prosthetic thickness on him so I can
devise a way of using kind of flat
molding it where and also you've got to
remember that there's the colors and the
layers that are needed within that
makeup so what I did was I devised wave
we injected
the layers in which are two layers with
the red and then the gray on top and
then that's applied to him in 18 pieces
and then the rest is all filled in it
salt alesis locked down with tulisa's so
there we go we also had this structure
where we had that we have it like a
two-piece case which were devised which
we put on him just to kind of give us a
lineup of his entire map of the actual
prosthetics themselves so that kind of
saves time and we had it down to two
hours 47 minutes well eventually and
what was it to start with that about
seven during the testing obviously yeah
I mean cuz you had the luxury of time
and you know and but then everybody kind
of latches onto anything says how long
it takes it doesn't you know and it got
better and better and we had a fantastic
crew of five people running around David
every morning and David Lee went into
such an armed state that was fantastic
he just relaxed and you know he went
through that what those tattoos also
tell you the story of his life yeah you
don't realize yes sir because it because
if you look within every tattoo there
was a scene which isn't in the final
movie which does explain his entire life
so the keloid scarring actually explains
you know his wife and his child and
everything else within that so also
there was another reason why I was keen
to have it in so many sections as well
as that if there was a change within
that story of any kind that came up
during the script I wouldn't be had the
time to create a brand new prosthetic in
a two or three piece so I could take off
sections and replace them so there were
other reasons for breaking it down into
those sections it was I remember it was
not just paint it was my yes yeah it was
a really fun I looked into the keloid
structures you know and if you look if
you start digging into that structure
and you see how the skin is then carved
into in reality and then its heat and
then it heals the healing process and
how it raises its it's all down to
degrees of you know millimeters and
you're going to see a wonderful display
of that a full-body display downstairs
in the lobby later on yes so here we've
got nebula played by Karen Gillian yeah
nebula Wow she was a massive challenge
because to be honest nebula was the one
that took a
while a crack in a big way because
there's a symmetry there you've got the
symmetry you have a kind of a as a
texture to it it has it has a real kind
of Sheen to that makeup and I didn't I
want it to be as thin as possible so
Karen very kindly shaved her head which
made him gave us a lovely shape that we
had and also I didn't want it to kind of
move and buckle around the neck area and
knowing that she was going to be very
physical in this movie so her neck is
actually it's just hers just paint and
continuing the line edge down into that
from the prosthetic and we have certain
kind of elements that we use to get the
singer the symmetry by using vac form
pieces that cut out sort of templates
really which are done in the foyer as
well you see where we can airbrush
through them and keep that rhythm going
all the way through now you had a lot of
different hair work on a lot of the
characters but then on a lot of the
women you had some very futuristic
hairstyles yeah it gave us a chance to
sort of do a lot of more fashion type
work as well which is really exciting to
do because it was you know kind of gave
us a chance does it'll be out there and
like I said for people to kind of relate
to the fact that we were in different
galaxies not just the one so that kind
of gave us a chance to do different
colored aliens but also you know we
really exaggerated it was really good
fun it was really good and you'll see a
number of those down in the lobby later
on too well thank you so much Michael
for coming up and sharing sharing your
expect you everybody
and we'll ask the nominees to take their
seats please welcome for foxcatcher bill
Corso bill is credited as the makeup
department head this is the third Oscar
nomination for bill he has won Oscar for
lemony snicket a series of unfortunate
events bill recently finished work
working on Star Wars and will soon be
working on Marvel's Deadpool with Ryan
Reynolds please welcome Dennis lyddiard
then this is credited as the key makeup
artist this is the first Oscar
nomination for Dennis and then it's just
completed work on geo storm with gerard
butler and jim sturgess and will soon be
working on arms and dudes starting jonah
hill and Bradley Cooper now bill and
Dennis I believe that you have two
special guests we do I think we're lucky
enough to have a Steve Carell and
Channing Tatum
hi Jan how you doing Steve you were
great in this movie well listen man
you're the one that got the oscar
nomination thanks to it thanks then
these guys were great great backup in
this movie fantastic I think I think we
did our head to be honest our trio of
actors and our director are being given
Awards right now in santa monica at the
Independent Spirit Awards so that is why
they could not be here but I I think we
did get one clip that we could show hi
Bill sorry I can't be there tonight but
I just wanted you to know that working
with you was a fantastic experience I
think that you are a true artist you are
clearly a leader in your field the time
that we spent together I thought was
collaborative and more importantly I
feel like I gained a really strong
friendship who am I talking to bill
Corso to have I work with him oh okay
foxcatcher foxcatcher he wears
turtlenecks a lot yes nice nice guy and
we're back I just wanted to say really
has been an honor work with you
congratulations on all your success
completely deserving and in all
sincerity I think you are the best bill
Corso
you were really good too I thought your
makeup was the better in the movie it
was very nice okay you two had a very
unique challenge in this taking John du
Pont with steve carell taking mark
schultz with Channing Tatum taking David
Schultz with Mark Ruffalo and in so many
cases producers directors don't want to
lose the look of the of the actor yeah
that's about it that's this case it was
a different situation that's a big thing
I mean you here and on every movie as a
makeup artist you know whatever you do
don't lose the actor you know we always
want to see the actor you want to see
the name above the marquee and this was
one of those amazingly rare
opportunities when I had a conversation
with the director he said I can't I
can't see you know I said I said to him
I said I can't pitcher Steve Carell in
this movie when I read the script and he
said he can't be Steve Carell cannot be
in this movie John du Pont needs to be
in this movie the character of John du
Pont because I hired Steve because I
thought as an actor he's going to bring
something interesting to the role but he
cannot be Steve Carell at all and and I
said well I that makes me nervous I go
anytime we do a makeup on somebody no
matter how good the makeup is the the
public the press is very quick to point
out wow that's a famous guy covered in
prosthetics that's it's nerve-racking
for makeup artists because you don't
want to be responsible for you know
taking people out of a movie or you know
not serving the story so you're always
walking a fine line but Bennett Miller
tays credit it's a phenomenal artist
director said that is not your problem
your problem is to do the best makeup
you can make him a believable character
make him a believable man of great
wealth and in history and and and if I
correct it if properly enough Steve acts
it properly then hopefully in about
three seconds will
fake the audience into thinking you met
he's he's this guy he's this character
and they won't be looking at Steve
Carell and and and the other actors to a
lesser degree said you know were the
same way they wanted to honor the real
people is a true story so they really
wanted to become these guys and to honor
their look and legacy I think we
certainly saw that in this film here
we've got three pictures of Steve Carell
that really show the changes that took
place here maybe you can tell us a
little bit about what the process was
here well you know with Steve it was you
know when you're told you he's got to be
unrecognizable it's like what okay what
about Steve makes him recognizable he's
a very recognizable hair eyebrows he's a
very distinct profile so how can we
change that so we we we played around
with well DuPont I used upon
interestingly Bennett didn't care if he
looked anything like the real John du
Pont no one knows what John du Pont
looks like but he looks so unlike Steve
Carell I thought that's a good enough
place to start as any um and DuPont in
if you've seen the movie he refers to
himself and did refer to himself as the
golden eagle and the irony being he has
a very Eagle like profile so I i put a
prosthetic that that you know change
Steve's nose and profile and and I also
incorporated a brow piece that got rid
of his eyebrows which which did a lot to
take it away from Steve and it also
allowed me to alter the anatomy of his
eyes and make give him a little age
because we were aging Steve a bit and
then you know it's studying DuPont again
DuPont had tiny little teeth said steve
has big movie star teeth so we gave him
we gave him a set of dentures with
little fake teeth and and we added
plumpers to really distort the shape of
his mouth which we kind of did with the
other gentleman as well and and then
finally you know we have the I have
quickly have to say we had the great
Katherine Gordon as our department at
hair stylist who happens to be here
tonight and and catherine was
instrumental in helping you know create
a look for see where we took his
hairline
back and we grade his hair out actually
let a lot of his own hair gray show
through which he doesn't really do and
and and that all combined with a paint
job that was meant to you know give the
impression of that really translucent
blue bloody type look and then finally
you know the little thin eyebrows and
brown contact lenses I mean there's a
lot of little things going on and every
little bit you know I put a fake lip on
them to give them kind of like a you
know a softer lip line all those little
details you know but there was also a
great deal of painting a lot of painting
a lot it's to take a if as a makeup
artist if you know to take someone with
the dark swarthy Mediterranean skin tone
and make them pale and translucent is is
quite the task and to do it every day
for 40 some odd days that matches is a
bit of a challenge and especially when
you've got a director and this is this
was Dennis's like daily you know routine
who would just come up like James Gunn
may have done it and just stare at the
makeup a go on it doesn't look real to
me oh there's a Senate look I don't know
if that looks quite right so wait you
know I relied on Dennis to food finish
Steve's makeup and we do this with each
of the guys and spin them around and say
alright tell me what's wrong what
doesn't look right because you know when
you get on set but the director and the
DP are going to be staring at it with a
you know like a lens and make sure that
it's going to be perfect Dennis you had
a great great change on Channing here
thank you you know I mean really really
such an unusual look sort of all the way
through here tell us what you've got
going here well when Bill called me and
talked to me about the project and told
me that I would be primarily taken care
of Chan and I kind of knew the story
from when when this first happened and I
remember when the brothers had won gold
medals I started to look at a lot of
pictures of wrestlers a lot of guys that
are fighters and live in the world of
combat so to speak and one thing really
jumped out to us when Bill and I would
talk about it and that's that there the
cartilage in their nose really starts to
break down their noses flatten out their
chins start to really protrude and
and their foreheads kind of protrude so
in profile they just get this really
flat profile so in talking to bill we we
decided to kind of you know to try and
go after that look to make it look like
our you know our movie stars were had
grown up in the world of combat of
fighting so um and half their lives with
the phase in a mat person his armpit
yeah so we started off what you'll see
is a with a nose appliance on chan to
get rid of that real pretty knows he has
to kind of kind of given a broken nose
and then we also put plumpers up his
nose to widen the base of his nose and
kind of pull the tip of his nose down
because keep in mind with all the
makeups on Mar on channing and on mark
these guys had to go wrestle and i had
to hold up to some pretty intense
wrestling we couldn't tell them to not
do stuff in the ring that just was not
going to happen they couldn't think
about the fact that they were in makeup
and then the cauliflower ears as well
which wrestlers are notorious for and
then to pull chins changed his polish
jaw forward a little bit and changes
matthew or lower plumpers that push the
bottom lip out and kind of pulled his
jaw forward and helped out and then
interestingly enough with mark we had
top and lower plumpers made for him but
he only wore the top which flattened out
his nose and his in his jaw line and
everything and then his hairline was
shaved well back as the real guys and
then we painted a broken nose on him and
out of the added the cauliflower ears on
him ironically but Ruffalo you know I
get more people come up to me and saying
yeah they could see Steve he's wearing a
big makeup and Channing and there's
something really wrong about Channing
quite can't put my finger on it but I
could had no idea was Mark Ruffalo like
more people are surprised about
Ruffalo's change which is again he's a
very distinctive looking guy you know
you ruggedly handsome guy but by doing
the hair thinking we did to me the beard
and we kind of romantic yer the beard to
look more like Dave Schultz and you know
we got we had Dave Schultz his family
you know come and visit the set and
they were you know again no greater you
know honor to have them say you know
first of all they didn't want to go near
Steve because he hits he looked like and
had such a vibe about him but the fact
that you know Mark so look like the dad
the kids you know and his wife it was
really really touching and I think you
even wore the real Dave Schultz his
glasses you know like to really really
become these guys and I'm but it is true
I mean you do these makeups you do them
at such a high level and trying to
maintain a a realistic I mean literally
to your eye you know try kind of
perfection and then they would go and
they and they would kill each other I
mean they practice wrestling for six
months and these guys really went at it
and you know you know just no holds
barred slapping each other and chanting
you know we beat the hell out of himself
in this movie and and the fact that all
those makeups you know hold up I think I
think there was one day on wrestling
that we saw an ear fly was flying
through the flying through frame on the
monitors was that a mouth piece Minh
hello wasn't here you know and and you
know in like in against do we see
chantix tattoos you know we're covering
Channing's tattoos and there's all these
little things that you know that we
don't think about but you know imagine
doing you know a portrait painting you
know that you're going to hang in the
gallery except it's on a moving canvas
and then now you've got to do that exact
same portrait painting every day and and
I said to the director I said well you
know look we're we we've done movies
before we've done these kind of makeups
before it's hard and it's under great
scrutiny but you know the actors acting
and the cameras moving and you know
there's there's other cameras and you're
cutting around and you know that it's
film you know we got we have a lot of
leeway and and yellow right he said well
you haven't seen my movies have you I
mean and I had one of the glaad great
things about having Dennis with me was
Dennis had worked on Moneyball with
bennett miller at the director and and
embedded said I've got it he has no I
like to shoot in big close-ups and I
like to stay on them for a really long
time so and you'll see in some of the
clips that's brutal for any man any
makeup you know and you're as a mega
Roger sitting there going okay that's
enough okay you can cut now
act do something other than your eyes
you know please all right well let's
take a look at all of this I want to
thank Steven chanting for being here and
and thank you to our nominees so please
welcome all of our Oscar nominees back
on stage before we start our question
and answer portion I'd like to read
remarks made a couple of years ago by
Steven Spielberg at the producers Awards
when he received the David Oh Selznick
award no one can succeed alone an
evening like this reminds me that every
film and TV show nominated tonight
someone reached out to give their hand
whether all of us are working together
or competing inside this very small
creative community we're always holding
somebody's hand and I'm grateful to feel
all of your hands holding mine right now
we're going to get started with a
question and answer period here and in
the aisle there are individuals with
microphones so if you have a question
please raise your hand and they'll bring
the microphone over to you so that
everybody can can hear your question and
also if you would please just ask one
question if you have other questions
wait until somebody else has an
opportunities so that everybody gets
gets a chance here all right okay who do
we have a question from
hello a question for all of you guys in
doing a movie obviously there's other
makeups from other films in your
specific niche that have been done
sports films and so forth wondering if
there are any makeups that you looked at
and referenced from past movies and
creating your own makeups for your films
this is for everybody well I know for us
we we had enough we do really reference
movies you know we referenced we had we
were doing a true story so we reference
the real people and and and then you
know people that were similar to the
people that we were trying to characters
that we were trying to create in the
movie um that was obviously important to
us but yeah but I I don't know for the
rest of you definitely without we didn't
because it was a completely new universe
that we were creating so we had to start
from scratch and I mean we did get
pictures from the artists at marvel that
kind of had suggestions of what they
were requesting but that was also way
before we knew knew which actors were
going to play those parts so they
weren't actually that they weren't
actually that helpful but we kind of
then built on those once we knew the
actor was coming and once we knew what
color they were going to be so kind of
built it on that kind of situation and
also we had a good chance to sort of
really create on our movie which was
really amazing for us being the creative
types yeah but every time on a movie you
have concepts that come in and then you
you redo things but when there's life
casts turn up that's when it really
counts because everybody is so
individual those actors have features
that you can accentuate and that's
really what we wait for is the moment
that the casting is locked and we get
those life casts i referenced for Rafe
90s 1930s films in general looking for
that film star look the 1i chosen the
end was that a full book I don't think I
pronounced that right but and he was of
just a very famous Don it just said
really well on race features and he's
hairstyle and moustache
yeah for us I think it was just looking
at referencing real characters the agent
would age in a similar way to Tilda
Swinton for their Madame D character but
you know I always look I remember seeing
you know the first time I saw the
Godfather and looking at that aging
makeup that the great dick smith dead on
Marlon Brando and how he created that
character and you see what what Marlon
Brando really looked like at that time
and that I always have that make up it's
my favorite makeup of all time and I
always have it in the background of my
mind in terms of creating a believable
character creating something that's
totally real and and sits with the actor
and doesn't isn't intrusive but but just
manages to elevate that the performance
with the actor and you know the one and
real quickly the one thing you do do
sometimes is for our sake you know like
we are actors are going to be really
wrestling and really beating each other
up so and and you know you do have in
the back your mind you know we we all
you know I'm a fan of makeup so I've
read every article and book on makeup
and I have lots of friends so obviously
you do makeup and I'm sure in the back
of my mind there's somebody saying well
i did a boxing movie and i use these
type of makeup just that really hold up
well so you do have that like you know
like reference point from a practical
standpoint like well like i may want to
try this because this might this might
hold up better than something else might
have so that does help I think to have
just a you know a catalog of techniques
and ideas and we have another question
yes right here um in guardians of the
galaxy I was interested in the makeup
for Ronan and what was the thoughts
behind that design process Ronan
actually was one of the illustrations
that sort of came to us and then we I
kind of researched him a bit more and
found that you know in in our film in
this original script he was going to
have to be naked and of being born out
of this this the blackpool that you saw
here so that we had to take that into
consideration and we already knew that
he would have to be this pacific blue
that we then developed this product to
sort of make that blue
and then the facial markings were with
the monks kind of sending them out to
wall so we had to make her product that
kind of stayed on on the skin as well
and was slightly rubberized in order to
sort of give you a texture as well but
that was basically based on the body
Ronan that's in the in the comic books
and then we took it a step further and
we we ended up doing a whole body makeup
and the whole tribal makeup as well
which actually didn't end up in the film
but so it was you know and he and the
purple eyes were the fact that I felt
that he he was trying to get this dark
blood into his system so he could become
a full God because he was a demigod so I
kind of felt that obviously the eyes
would that you know the veins in the
eyes and the color of the eyes would
reflect that so there was all that all
the thoughts behind you know how this
creature was sort of developed was was
to do with his galaxy and where he came
from and the type of blood he would have
in the type of you know the type of I
looked at all the spaceships that he
can't heal he lived in and and the
ancient writing and everything then
tried to include that in all the makeup
another question we have a question
right here hi this might be a question
for the moderator I was just wondering
why is hair and makeup the only category
that only has three movies nominated
when all the other categories have at
least five a great question
it is it has been the choice of the
members to keep the the number of three
and that comes from sort of a
self-preservation if you will a lot of
times this year is a great example where
there could have been five okay there
have been other years in the past where
there were maybe three great films and
the fourth and Phil fourth and fifth
film might have been a little
questionable when the makeup artists are
choosing the film's nominating the films
they know the makeup and hairstyling
what can happen sometimes so if it goes
out to 6,000 members who are voting who
may not be to expertise and makeup and
hair they might be voting for something
that they thought was really a great fun
movie and not necessarily picking the
best makeup so therefore it could happen
that of these five films and three were
really great or maybe even four we're
really great and that fifth one was a
little iffy and it could be that the
fifth one it's then that gets the gets
the award and so we are very very
protective of that and we want to make
sure that we give every year we give the
highest nominated films that we can
otherwise known as quality control
and it's a great question another
question all right right here hey this
is for the guardians of the galaxy good
people you created so many races do you
have any idea how many and was there
ever a point where you said this isn't
enough or okay stop we're getting ahead
of ourselves now ah that's a good
question isn't it there were earlier
yeah there's a lot of there are a lot of
racism it to be honest I was I was
concept in New possible aliens literally
into the movie itself and clearing them
and they would appear later in the movie
it was an ongoing process how did I say
yeah I just never that's why we that's
why we've got those wonderful women with
the big hairdos in the usual fashion
what because I didn't stop I can't just
kick it was evolving it was evolving as
the movie continued allowed us to
introduce these new characters and also
it gave James a chance to find out how
the world worked that he had created and
you know and what he you know to you
know enhance that by creating and giving
us the opportunity to put new characters
in there but it was also good that we
could actually make creatures that were
like interact you know like that i had
interbred as well so if you see some of
the three-tiered Mohawks you see them
with David's and characters and then you
see them in the prison with my great
nice to see a cross-pollination of
characters and which is kind of cool we
had different kind of colors for people
and they had different kind of
prosthetics down their jaw line some had
them on the foreheads so there was
somewhere to start in a world and then
it just began to cross over and evolve
yeah another question hi I have a
question for Francis I wanted to know
how you styled Tilda Swinton's wig how
you set and styled it I put it on them
the little wooden sticks every day that
was to get the ways in it originally
because we only had to cover it for Duke
for three or four days I did never have
to
I have it redress completely and Julie
dartnall who was one of my right-hand
men along with my other artists normal
web and Emma mash and hike America they
worked on this team where you can never
manage it alone you have to have a help
in hand and then then the switches on
the top the two separate switches were
also rolled on sticks and then
afterwards if ever needed anything extra
once it was dressed out it would be with
hot irons just to put the crisp edge to
the wave into it and the tiny back
pieces you'll see it's all downstairs
were also waived in the same way another
question right here congratulations to
oil the nominees my question is you
represent three different genres in
contemporary drama futuristic adventure
or time period which ones do you think I
probably wore before in different units
in previous movies but which one do you
think Lee requires more research more
challenging it is amazing isn't it that
we have three completely different you
know apple orange and a peach you know
it's a and I you know I have no idea how
the Academy picks out of that group I
mean it's really hard George Clooney
once famously said you know if everybody
put on a Batman costume then you could
maybe judge who is the better actor you
know and it's it's hard for us because
we are such a varied group you know I
mean I you know knowing I mean we were
researching real people you know trying
to make realistic makeups they were
creating an entire world of characters
many Union how can you compare those two
to another and then you know and then
what they were doing is you know
creating a you know a group of family of
amazing looking you know characters for
a period movie that you know it's it's
it's wonderful about our category and
and horrific about our category that
it's so diverse and complicated but you
know it's um it's amazing I think it's
amazing that we that's why Leonard is so
so you know keen on saying that there's
three winners you know because it's so
diverse you
no we have time for one more question we
have one right here hi my question is
for the grand Budapest hotel what was
the concept behind Agatha's makeup that
was written in the script by Wes he
described her birthmark her port wine
stain as I'm looking at the peninsula of
the Mexican Peninsula so we am we didn't
have Saoirse until we were starting the
film so I had the map drawn out I did it
on four or five different sizes I did
six or seven different tones of port
wine staining and then I used a model in
England and placed them all sent it to
where's he chose his favorite from that
and then Saoirse arrived and we did it
and shot on it it was but it was
definitely in the script all right be
sure and watch the oscars tomorrow night
ABC and you'll see how these great
winners are able to see who actually
takes the statute and please join us
downstairs in the lobby you'll see
wonderful displays ok thank you q